[Music]
foreign
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders
thank you for inviting me this is such a
unique pleasure for me
because one of the most memorable
memories of growing up
is of me playing a taki which
is a card game that you invented in
israel but probably i
played so many more of your games that i
don't even know about just because i'm
looking behind you and i'm assuming that
a lot of these games
are the creation of your own hands yeah
uh
well yes in israel i'm very well known
because of the taki
which is the most famous
israeli game actually it's a similar
game to uno but it's more advanced
and both games uno and taki are are
based on a very very good
classical game which used to be played
in
regular cards it's called crazy eights
uh
while uno is just you know the crazy
eights with different design but
in tacky what i did i took it one or two
steps further and make it a very
strategic and tactical game especially
when you play two players because i
added a lot of cards and i added a lot
of
rooms rules yes and uh
and this is why taki became so popular
because it's an extremely good game
i i have to say that i remember every
time and
every time somebody put the reverse or
the two plus
it killed me it's such a
or changed color such a great game take
me back
a few years and talk to me about this
idea of creating games
and you know using creativity to create
engagement
among people i think that's fascinating
and i'd love to understand
how you even got to where you are yeah
uh this is one of the questions which
which i'm asked the most you know how
how well how one decides to become a gay
inventor because there it's not the
profession like you know a lawyer or a
doctor or a teacher or whatever
uh and actually most people my age you
know nowadays you can learn
the trade you can people go to schools
to design school
and and they learn how to design games
but when i was
you know four years ago even a little
bit more when i started
it was an accident when i like well
you you stumble upon
this opportunity and i started with uh
designing wooden toys with a carpenter
friend
really it was very successful but
unfortunately
making wooden games is a very very low
tech industry
and it's hard to make money yeah and in
the first year in the first year i
realized that ip is important
if you don't have an ip if everybody can
do whatever you do
then you at a certain point you will
fall because somebody will come with a
better
design with a better price
and better marketing or whatever and you
will find yourself struck
struggling
what year are we right now
yeah when is this and we are talking
about
when i when i started yeah i started
1978 okay
and uh for a year until 1977 78
and for a year i was involved in wooden
toys and then i realized that i have to
have something
which can be protected by copyright or
by name or brand or whatever
and then i moved to games printed games
and i also realized that if you have a
strong ip
which is easy to manufacture and it's
not so low-tech you know you have to
you know wooden games or wooden toys you
have to do one by one you know it's a
very very
yeah pretty soon process you know
if you have a good game and you have
good design you put it in the printing
machine and then it runs
sure and you can you can reach numbers
and that's what i realized in the
beginning and later on i realized the
value of a brand when you have a brand
which you worked very hard to build and
with this brand you create
strong relationships with your customers
you become protected because steve jobs
taught me
something very important unfortunately i
never met him but he said something
which is a beacon to my thoughts you
know he said
once i remember many years ago he said
you know you buy microsoft because you
have to
but you buy apple because you love
and i said to myself this is it i have
to develop
loving relationship with my customers i
have to love them
i have to appreciate them i have to
serve them and hopefully they will love
me back
and if you look behind me there are
millions
and millions of people around the world
who love my products and i'm protected
by the love
they will go into the store asking for
my
game i don't have to struggle with the
store now
to do me a favor and keep my games in
the store they need to have it in the
store or at least those that are
in demand because people ask for them
and that's what i did that's what i
created in 40 years it takes a long time
or a lot of money or both fine that's
inspiring
talk to me about this idea of of
family style games and you know people
engaging with each other
is that is that sort of a motive in in
what you're doing because all these
games
their interaction between people right i
remember one of the highlights of
playing these games for me was
friends would come over from school in
in the neighborhood
and we would just to take out tataki or
eretz
and we would play and it created such a
nice
feeling between us as friends and that
we wouldn't have necessarily gotten in
any other way
well as you see i mentioned steve jobs
as a teacher
and i have another teacher which gave me
a
tip of my life and it's appleton
plato yep and he said
that people express themselves through
another
i mean we need the other to express who
we are
and if you understand that fully
you understand that everything that
engage people together
in the end no matter what happens in the
world
people will need that if it serves the
basic need for people to interact
fully this is a product that will always
always be in demand of course you have
to be good
it has to be affordable it has to be
suitable to the to the to the time to
the
whatever to the technology but
interacting
helping people to interact and enjoying
and benefit from this interaction
will always always be in demand and
that's what i realized in my career
and uh what i realized is that people
need
the joy of meeting uh and
and all my big games are based on that
notion
yes sorry it's okay my
um my my games are family games what is
called
what is called family games and family
games have two
two important traits or characteristics
one is they have to appeal to the adults
without frustrating the young yes and on
the other hand
they have to
challenge the young and not be boring to
the adults yeah
so you have to find that area in which
there is no difference between adults
and children
and because if if the parent plays with
a child
as a favor you know he's doing it as a
chore you know
the child knows that he does not enjoy
the interaction
enough to enjoy the meeting and to get
the full benefit from this interaction
so my job
is to interact with the parent because
the children want to play anyway
they will play anything just because
they love to play
but parents need a lot of push a lot of
help
to fall into this trap i call it a trap
yeah of doing something just for the joy
of it because as adults
we don't choose things because we enjoy
them we cannot afford it
so we are used to do things because they
benefit us
yes and to do things just because
it's fun
it's difficult for adults it's not
difficult for children
right no that that makes a lot of sense
uh so we have just about 10 minutes left
and i
i have to get into this into the mind of
a game creator
you sit down and let's take taki for
example or any other game
what process do you have to go through
to come up with this masterpiece that
then millions of people around the world
enjoy spending hours and hours on
yeah first of all it it it takes a long
time to make something very simple
and games must be simple if you want to
interact with a lot of people and you
want to
engage adults and children together so
to create something which is very very
simple yet intriguing
you need to know how the mind works
in order to create an arena
into which you invite people from
different cultures different age
different mentalities different
education and you want to interact
so many people you have to know what is
the common denominator not the low
but the common denominator of
all people around the world and i
mentioned
one of them it's uh the the
common denominator of all people
is we're interactive creatures we want
to interact
through interaction we get realness
we get to be in touch with ourselves
through the other we cannot get in touch
with ourselves
we cannot our self is their interaction
with another there is no self without
the other
so when i want to create a good game
first of all i have to be
very very much indulged with what
makes us joyful
i want to have a joyful feeling
and joyful meeting and i use the game
as a tool to get that right so i'm not
thinking
so much about the game mechanism
but i'm thinking about the experience
that i want to take people through
and the mechanism helps me to bring them
to the points i want them to get
and what tools do you use i mean do you
just use a pen and paper and you start
jotting down ideas or you talk to
friends
i mean what happens from this moment of
eureka
to the moment where it's in the store
there is no there is no
uh method
it's chaotic it's totally chaotic if you
know if you're an inventor or creator
or an artist and you look for a method
you're in the wrong business
there is no method there is only the the
desire there is only the passion and the
curiosity
to to find the leads and the tips
and and and the ideas to start another
journey which will bring you to that
algorithm which will drive people
to indulge with what's what you you
prepared them
to you know you you prepare something
for people like
like a meal you say okay come test my my
meal
you never test it before maybe it's
similar to something but this particular
meal
you never taste it please try it
and as a chef you know
you're very anxious to see whether they
like it or not because it's a new
experience
and whenever they do i'm happy every
time it's the same
anxiety will they like it will they love
it will they
buy it how many games have you created
uh over a hundred over a hundred games
actually if you mean there are they're
not
100 skus there are 100 different
algorithms but from each algorithm
there are some numerous variations you
know in different countries
wow so out of those out of those 100
plus
how many how many overall failed as in
they didn't pick up people didn't enjoy
them versus
people got so intense enhanced by them
probably i can say throughout the years
well you cannot divide it to two it's
not
binary it's uh it's like some are best
sellers
fortunately some are total failures and
most of them are in between they're just
nice games
yeah some of them are good but not best
sellers yeah
but fortunately you have i have some
best spellers one of them
is one of the top selling game in the
world you know yes
it's uh it sells in 35 36
countries wow and it sells in millions
and did you did you get a chance to play
it yourself
tacky say it again did you get a chance
to play it yourself
of course sometimes some of my games
i've still played today because i love
them
oh that's amazing most of them i'm bored
they cannot play them anymore because i
played them so much you know
and and it's not fun for me to play them
anymore especially
i don't play them anymore because they
are finished there there is nothing i
can do to improve them and they are done
those that i can still improve i keep
playing so heim the golden question is
when you play taki do you feel like you
have some sort of upper hand because
you've been thinking about this game so
much or
do you find yourself in a position where
yeah
people are still beating me because of
because the game
because of the nature of the game when
you play one-on-one
in taki your capability
and your expertise is an advantage
so i'm a good player but if i play
against
another good player then where even so
if i play against a rookie
i will beat him you know not every time
but throughout time i will
i will devour him and i do it
sometimes because i play we have we have
an app
we have a tacky app and like you can
play it's a wonderful app
you can play it with others all around
the world
and if if a rookie comes and play with
me i beat him
i don't mind i will crash it
well when i'm back in israel after this
whole corona thing you're gonna
fulfill a live dream of mine and and
entertain me for one game of taki
and then i'll always be able to know
that uh i tried beating
but if you're a good if you're a good
player uh
then we will be even so i'm just i'm
starting to train today
that's that's the idea okay so we have
some time time
what is it where does this curiosity
come from how i mean you could be
you know you could do startups you can
do drawings you can
do architecture why why board games
board games well actually
it was uh just luck you know i started
with wooden toys
because a friend of mine was a carpenter
and he suggested we do something
together
but then when i started to be involved
in the toy
industry i fell in love with it because
it involves
things which bring joy yeah and
and i was so fascinated with the idea
that i
i can make a living with bringing joy
and it
captured my soul and i cannot think of
myself doing anything else in the world
because
you know being a mechanical engineer
as i am and using your expertise as
a mechanical engineer and using my my
knowledge
as now as a in psychology and philosophy
yeah
and and gaming and everything
to create products that bring joy
it's more than one can ask in a lifetime
you know
that's wonderful making a good living
from this
yeah is is is more than i expected just
just being able to live from doing what
i love
is enough well your sense of your
personal fulfillment just just
transcends this zoom call which i think
is is beautiful
before we leave i'd love to know three
words that you think would
best describe yourself or if i would ask
anybody who's playing your games
how would they describe you in three
words
wow it's a difficult question to ask yes
uh i think curiosity is the first
word i am a curious person anything
which makes my curiosity
flourish you know i it makes me like a
child you know i love it i
love it if i run across something which
fascinates me
it's it's wonderful i love people that
can drive my curiosity and fulfill my
curiosity yeah
the second thing i love people i love
interaction with people i
i believe that through interaction with
people uh
we become more more whatever more human
more smart more wise more happy
more joyful more more so
whatever you want into your life you
always get it
through interactivity so
this is the second word which will
describe me
very interactive person yeah
and the third
is you know i always
look behind my shoulder or i'm always
afraid of missing an important message
that i could collect from life i mean
you know
when you're when you're an artist or you
are a creative person
you get messages you get messages people
say something
and suddenly it's it's something which
spring you know it it it
it makes you jump from your from your
skin because you got a crazy idea or a
wonderful idea or whatever
and i always live with the fear that
there was something out there
that i missed so i'm alert all the time
i'm alert so the third word will be
alert
i'm 70 years old this no i passed 70.
and i'm still alert and i hope i will be
still alert
for many years to come and you're still
creating games right
oh yeah yeah crime continue doing good
for the world thank you so much
thank you very much this is wonderful
and i hope
it was interesting for the listeners
fascinating thank you
okay